off of his turnover getting back in the
picture
davis drives lost the handle
damien lilly looked like he jammed his
finger stealing the basketball from
anthony davis
asking for a sub looked over to terry
stotts who's gonna call a timeout anyway
lillard in some in some pain right now
144 remaining it's a laker bludgeoning
as we take a look at the damon lillitt
reaching
here's where you hurt that finger on the
left hand
get or a foul it's just a high low play
and they do a tremendous job sealing
and this was a good touch pass
there's lillard in the back
left a couple of minutes ago july
as you see lillard again
with the avery bradley opting not to
come to the bubble they've missed avery
bradley damien has suffered a dislocated
left
index figure he did go back and get
x-rays but they were
negative so he's staying on the bench
with those fingers take
mike was it up thank you cassidy let's
see
was it on the foot i think it was mike
yep that's what it looks like great
camera work as usual
by our camera crew